début de la vidéo dès qu'on commence
pour ceux qui regardent en replay sur
youtube
n'oubliez pas que vous pouvez vous
abonner à la chaîne youtube de
tchatche.com c'est juste en dessous ce
petit truc s'abonner donc comme ça vous
ratez pas les live que je fais ou que
fabien fait ou qu'on fait avec fab et
qu'on met en replay en replay sur cette
chaîne moi j'ai commencé un petit peu en
avance alive donc encore une fois si
vous regardez en redif ou faut un petit
peu avancé sur le petit curseur le temps
que j'allume que j'avais fait que le
stream est mis en en place le tweet le
machin les tchats et je pense que je
vais commencer par quelques petits
bullet histoire de se remettre un peu en
forme parce qu'hier j'étais enfin j'ai
fait j'ai fait l'arenal hier pour ceux
qui nous regardent et j'étais vraiment
épuisée je n'arrivais pas à jouer
c'était très désagréable pour moi et
j'imagine pour les joueurs parce que la
prochaine fois je serai de plus en mode
3 de la prochaine fois que je fais ça et
et du coup ce soir ma ce que j'aimerais
faire ce que j'ai envie de faire c'est
de commencer par 2 3
par quelques petites bulles est
l'histoire de chauffeur un petit peu
parce que ça me fait plaisir
tout bêtement enfin certes aucun rapport
avec vous en fait le truc vraiment pour
le fair play et après est ce que l'on se
fait un petit tournoi
peut-être parce que la semaine prochaine
la semaine prochaine je serai à budapest
et on n'aura peut-être pas le tournoi du
mois donc est-ce qu'on se fait un petit
tour et puis tout ce que vous voulez
voilà donc je dis est ce qu'après on
fait un petit tournoi peut-être je vais
mettre le cha dû vérifier donc le truc
soit bien démarré mais j'en suis quasi
sûr
voilà sûrement ouais je me tape la pub
de mon propre trio final et on va se
faire quelques petits allez je vais
faire deux trois quatre bullet après
j'aimerais bien vous organisé un petit
tournoi et puis on peut un peu discuté
c'est un peu des gens donc ça c'est bon
et je veux juste faire je vérifier de
trucs temps mais je prends la pub la
plus longue du monde
je prends la pub du mec qui met du
déodorant coiffe on s'en fout totalement
voilées donc par ton non non non pas du
3 minutes pas du 3 minutes pas du 3
minutes va faire quelques petits bullet
histoire deux histoires de sentir si je
peux de nouveau calculé correctement et
voir un peu l'échiquier nommé hier
c'était vraiment je me suis assis devant
l'écran je voyais rien là j'ai
l'impression que ok je veux un petit peu
que je gagne ou que je perde je sens que
ça va quoi je sais de nouveau jouer aux
échecs
c'est également un truc très important
c'est un peu mon métier de base 1 n'ont
pas forcément de jouer mais quand même
alors allez envoyer pions dessus c'est
peut-être un truc avec fu g4 la quittez
pas mana
je suis quand même faire des 5 l on va
envoyer le pion commençant à faire 1 4
comme ça on va faire à trois on va
prendre ici
le fougueux 4 comme 120 peu recontrôler
les cases c'est pas mal joué de sa part
échanger les dames et va peut-être faire
ces trois bons l'adversaire joue assez
bien j'avais peut-être l'éperon bekkat
en premier avec un réseau de matha c'est
sympa touchant même serval à jour je
revois kof
je revis kébé 4 quand même menace le fou
à deux menaces à deux menaces qui est
des trois échecs qui est pro f 2 temps
je fais un petit truc sympa je peux
commencer par à 2 sur foi de jeu revient
en b 4 ok là j'ai envie de me faire
super plaisent avec foix iii qui
fonctionne à moitié mais en apprenant f2
maintenant la reprendra tron va menacer
le fou du coup quand il prend à deux on
va prendre un chien fait refouler 5 et
tout raser et là dessus c'est un peu se
dépêchant affaires food et 5
certes il se défend super bien quand
même faut le souligner il joue pas mal
il joue pas mal à prendre des cas plus
tôt et on essaie de prendre des deux
heures il aurait été malin jusqu'au bout
on va jouer autant à foin
ok bon ça fait plein de ressentir un peu
de vitesse le mec refuse de jouer
évidemment il a senti la puissance à
hasnon comment ça détend de devoir de
nouveau de savoir jouer aux échecs alors
le mec sympa une professeure d échec
enfin le mec et la lan avant on avait
joué deux chaises coach la professeure d
échec les mecs sont chauds les mecs sont
chaud patate pour t'apprendre à l'e mail
de prendre du fric c'est clair les mecs
veulent te prendre du fric en apprenant
les échecs ça ça se sent est-ce qu'il va
réussir à nous prendre du fric c'est un
peu la question qu'on se pose
notre dame en a cinq
peut-être pas mal ce qu'il fait chez pas
c'est peut-être pas mal mes impressions
un peu sur des six encaissés 1
en caisse arrêts et cylia blanc espagnol
a regardé au combat comme une professeur
ada rendina l'espère le mot bien née
muchas gracias pregunta on arrive c est
cela elle supprime à l'espagne en
louisiane du coup c'est pas si mauvais
pour les blanches parce que je fous
c'est ici elle c'est charles nnl chat et
qui fait ou une clin d'oeil avec qu'est
ce que je suis en train de faire bon
allez je suis plus concentré déjà j'en
parle espagnol quoi c'est n'importe quoi
les noms du coup du coup on va on va
voir on va voir ce que ça donne parce
que l'on s'est un peu perdu dans la
langue de cervantes
alors cette position honnête
qu'est ce qu'elle donne ont menacé le
maton va par là on encaisse le pion on
va les changer
mettre le pion à 6 ça mange pas de pain
va remettre la d'amoureux 5 et on va
pousser alors attendez faut toujours un
peu plus vite là je suis un peu lent
mais il peut pas prendre assez protégé
là
ça peut être pas mal ou pas
aïe aïe aïe
bon ok bon il nous a fait tomber mais ça
va ça va s'arranger pour sarah savoy les
trucs bon c'est faire tomber a bêtement
alors est ce que voulait faire un
tournoi enfin vous êtes chaud pourquoi
les mecs
vous êtes chauds pour faire quoi ce que
voulait faire un truc ce que voulait que
je fasse un peu de bullet je sais je
sais pas mais c'est ce que voulait faire
un tournoi
alors on oublie ça on va déjà faire une
soirée bleed ce samedi donc non
qu'est ce qui ne tue un jour je jouerai
peut-être faire 1 0 mais là aujourd'hui
c'est beaucoup mieux enfin je sens que
je joue aux échecs quoi puisque in tu
veux du bullet on peut se faire un
tournant à 20h30 aussi un jeu c'est pas
elle sait pas combien on est on va on va
voir on va laisser un peu le monde
arrivait je vous sens inactif dans le
chatt déjà jean machine piette et y en a
on a un adversaire solide alors il
restait le pion on va prendre du
cavalier l'on va on va un peu changer
notre fusil d'épaulé dire je veux dire
je veux dire j'ai commencé à regarder
des séries animées japonaises à fond et
je suis en train de regarder ans
montocchio goulard je sais pas si vous
connaissez
c'est hyper connu enfin bon moi je
découvre un peu la ja cavaliers à quatre
questions qui y perd quand même encore
mais qui sauverait en fait qui sauvent
en réalité rien du tout donc ouais je
sais pas si vous connaissez si vous
regardez mes mais chacun peut découvrir
les animés japonais je regardais pas du
tout je sais pas je me suis mis pas
l'air d'être hyper intello mais mais bon
ça se regarde gentiment le soir quand tu
veux quand tu veux te reposer et c
mais du coup je sais pas si vous
connaissez si vous connaissez pas à ce
que vous en pensez
belge vous attend dans le chat que vous
me disiez 1
en cela on va la perdre on va gagner la
prochaine j'avais entendu parler indycar
hikaru m lefranc gesac alors essayé de
le jour un peu dans l'esprit
enfin mais c'est complètement con quand
même mais bon je peux pas m'empêcher
ça a pas du tout aller s'ils jouent à
des trucs aussi débiles on est le
fourrage et de protéger la tour
je joue pas mal hein qu'est mais là on
peut pas selon l'idée de contre-attaquer
mais l'essai du chopper sa tour
si on peut
j'ai pas trop compris son truc foot
matour là haut
je suis très mal c'est plus qu'une
impression là mais bon on lu ton luth
ok c'est fun au moins comme partie a
offert ses 3
à quelle horreur au look est bon un peu
de sérieux mais j'ai pas réussi à parler
truc de go que boulay des animés
japonais temps j'étais diab animés
chinois sans faire exprès possible mais
ce mec qui meurent de pas mal joué
il m'a l'air de pas mal joué du coup on
va aller attaquer son roi on va planquer
les fous on va aller attaquer à la
brutale
vous enlevez les motos pression ou là il
ya des six là il ya des six bons quand
bien même un pas très grave
puis henry d'aller prendre g2 quand même
moi allez futsal à mettre le cavalier
angers 4 vous me connaissez un la
brutalité
ce qui me caractérise je pense va faire
dames 1
mais oui mais du temps à trouver alors
ça aussi c'est possible je me développe
et moi à ma tondeuse
c'était le piège que je tendais ce que
je peux commenté roland garros en même
temps que tu joues j'aimerais bien
qu'ils signent grâce à ken le survivant
death note c'est cool j'ai bien aimé
death note aussi lightning paris veut
pas rejouer c'est tellement petit slip
tous à la journée on parle de dargah où
l'on lit le chat tu as fait plaise quoi
on se fait une culture bon allez on va
le jouer solide
mais du coup à tokyo boulbon je suis en
train de regarder
je dois dire que j'apprécie c'est sympa
ça se regarde telle histoire de goulens
fait jeu presque sait ce que c'est une
goule cris de la mythologie perse je
crois ou arabes ou les deux d'ailleurs
ce que c'est quand même des cultures qui
sont assez proches
alors là à la goule allez dégage aller
ok mais là c'est moi qui vois rien où
j'ai une caisse de plus bon je vais bien
d un peu tout ça j'ai toujours du tour
h3 au cas où
peut-être un peu chiant là je sais pas
j'ai du mal encore à gagner les
positions gagnantes
je manque un peu de déconcentration les
positions gagnantes encore ça va revenir
la c4 j'ai fait n'importe quoi manque un
peu de concentration et positions
gagnantes nos jours c'est pas grave
après un peu lent à la souris
bon bah on essaie là on n'a pas de
message
on n'a pas de message aura pas de
message à part on n'a pas beaucoup de
messages à les mecs donne pas de riz
match alors que bon mais tellement
complètement gagnant que l'on s'arrêtait
de jouer quoi star cast dans un premier
temps on va remonter à 2006 soit je
propose on a un objectif on remonte à
2006 et après on discute dans un petit
truc qu'il faut connaissent pas mal joué
le dame b 6 c'est quoi ce bordel
chanson qui c'est ce qui fait le mec je
ressemble qui vous a fait toute une
combinaison de folie qui connaissait
c'est possible qu'il ait connu possible
possible qu assez assez assez bien joué
faut reconnaître c'est assez joli
écoutait on est parfois obligé de
reconnaître la beauté
il monte des des combinaisons adverse on
va faire qui avait cinq ans même revenir
on va venir là on va le pousser le pion
à mon avis ça ne fait pas très mal passé
plus chiant à revenir ici crache une en
or est ce que c'est parce que j'ai un
peu de la goësse que ce que je suis lent
puisque je parle des goules
non mais c'est des gaules
tu m'as drôle vif 2006 est en danger la
bon
ce qu'on va réussir à lui faire cavalier
ou six pour le maté à main soit la lande
et 3 mettant deux petites erreurs comme
ça ça devient très pénible à force on
n'y a pas de lag ça on peut le dire
officiellement
bon par contre à la souris là c'est pas
du tout ça
ok on l'a fait tomber à la dure allez on
va leur jouer dans un soft qui a dit
qu'il avait vu parasitaire parasites
j'ai vu aussi en fait je suis
complètement fou quoi j'ai eu plein de
trucs j'ai bien aimé les parasites aussi
j'ai bien aimé parasites osmose l'osm au
vote alors il veut fouiller car c'est de
la merde on va le faire rémy connaît ça
généralement tu vas peut être pas nue
c'est pas un truc que les gens
connaissent pas ont valu pousser ça on
va mettre la tour en 18 pouces à cinq
écoutes 1
c'est un peu le boxon n'a pas trop trop
de temps quoi j'utilise beaucoup de
temps elles tiennent pas mais bon là el
tiempo
j'en ressens qu'il réfléchit pas trop
quand même en face à un fin pas
l'impression qu'on a affaire à un
scientifique quoi qui n'est pas
scientifique fait très attention bas
mais on va lui encaissé son tueur f 5 g
est un pur ans et 6 ans il faire un
petit mur on va mettre le pion g6 soit
bien couvrir notre truc car dame ces
cinq échecs ça va nous faire des
vacances j'ai replacé le fou ici je
mette la tourache s'être mais je fais là
je vais faire de ces de l'art
contemporain si vous voulez les mecs là
c'est tard quand on sort un fait très
attention
ouais tour h7 fait très attention ses
contemporains du coup je reparle à quoi
je suis content contemporain en fait
très attention parce que d'apprendre ma
jeu c'est très très contemporain ah
tiens par contemporain dans ta gueule
dégage très attention bah il revient à
l'onf est un peu d'eux car si on tombe
n'a pas joué quatre au life une seconde
-o à lui il donne des pions il se fait
plaisir
ah c'est beau ça quand je vois quelqu'un
se faire plaisir comme ça moi j'ai envie
de me de chialer quoi car j'ai envie de
chalets là les mecs muffins ce qu'en dit
bon allez on s'en fout mais c'est le fou
ou soyons soyons gentleman mais pensons
printemps les mecs allons francs sur
échecs ont fait du printemps de partout
nombreuses thèses à les vins bien
prendre le pilon voilà c'est le beau jeu
je t'attaque pas la dame pour le moment
je te laisse en vie
allez hop manente l'attaquent oncle
attaque une deuxième fois fente la semi
attaque on va doubler les tours sur la
colonne b continuent à pousser ce qu'on
appelle dans le jargon une double adha
alors maintenant mettre laurent achats
mais pose ses pions parce qu'on le sent
un peu véhément
on va prendre une fois et on va les
faire damas six échecs
j'aurais dû commencer par damas six
malheureusement malheureusement il
fallait commencer par damas six mais mes
petits amis
alors on va prendre la nulle fallait
commencer par la bâtisse ont gagné des
tours prend b6 et c'est et mat
en plus je l' ai vu je peux en quoi je
n'ai pas joué encore une question qui
restera sans réponse à un rare ce qu'il
fait là dessus je vais passer de l'autre
côté avec la dame passe à l' enfer le
grand roque pour protéger le pion c7 et
on va faire à 6 on va chasser et e5 pour
que le foot dans la gueule bon alors là
le mec il s'est pris pour nous il donne
son cavalier écoute on ne le prend pas
donc le prendra en temps et en heure
tonton
le temps n'est pas venu de le manger
quand c'est quand le temps sera venu on
le mange rien nous sommes des goules
fera attention
bon ok alors maintenant que font les
goules aurait tellement de possibilités
c'est tellement talent une partie de
boules je t'ai dit qu'on le mange mais
en temps et en heure va le temps est
venu
quand même sympa la composition les mecs
non mais je suis pas tu as aujourd'hui
encore je suis pas tuer en méchoui fun
pour faire tourner un tour à chareyre on
n'a pas tué tué mais on s'est faits
plein ont joué avec toi qu'avec une
souris tu es d'une souris
bon allez
suivante avec g5 direct mais par contre
la g6 la hache 6 g5 je connaissais pas
tonton tu m'as appris quelque chose
trajet envie de me faire plaisir j'ai
envie de sacrifier une dame genre kf3
dame pour un f3 on s'en fou prend des
six les dames c'est de la merde je faire
dame prend des cadres du fou comme ça
s'ils pourront rien là je te prends là
et j'aurai h 8 en vue et s'y prend la
boule et calloc'h c'est de la merde
dégage alors là quand même fait quand
même très très attention
alors il va défendre à recommencer
parfois f6 ont évité dame g5 et
maintenant vas te faire dame pranger
karaté dame g7 matt acheter dit que les
tours c'était de la merde
bon bah oui mais bon enfin voilà très
très bien très très bien est arias
et dire qu'il joue que comptait plus de
2000 ça se fait pas mal et on va leur
parler au bout d'un moment enfin alors
popov c'est pas popol c'est popov lui
aller et b5 dégage h5 aurait tourné dans
le conceptuel 1 c'est l'art moderne
c'est ça je te pousse les pions par tous
cavaliers e4v de bouffer g3 je mette la
dame en effet si nice
attention popov alors tonton popov aux
banques tant à lui bouffer saha popov
on a peut-être fait du caca mais on le
fait avec des grands plaisirs
oui m'enfin il bouffe
voilà très bien aujourd'hui commencer
par les guerriers 17 c'est pas grave on
l'a fait bouffer un pion pas mal joué ça
de sa part a laissé très conceptuel on
est très mal ce qu'on peut survivre
non bon c'était dur c'était dur c'est un
peu too much quand même mais bon
et vas-y bouffe
c'est un peu chiant
je fais n'importe quoi je réfléchis en
plus
on va prendre là on va chasser on va re
ok on va chasser on va chasser à venir
au centre il ya les mouettes qui sont
complètement folle à côté de chez moi
ouais dans le truc c'est qu'on s'est mis
mal à la pendule haye adam prend médias
prise en b2 il n'a pas vu mais on s'est
mis mal à la pendule on a fait n'importe
quoi
alors est ce qu'on peut faire et prend
des six
ça n'a pas l'air très violent
alençon qui s'est un peu perdu dans dans
notre tactique
mais on reste très mal
pas je savais qu'on était très mal j'ai
senti mal
va se refaire la cerise vous inquiétez
pas
un système de longs très classique mais
bon
pas très pas très excitant popov l'émoi
de son prénom en train de dire ça
alors on essaie de gagner la colonne
c'est par notre petit plus en finale
avec le piquet en b3 pas mal fait on va
mettre la tour ans et 8 on va remettre
une pression là-dessus assez bien joué
les tours france est 3ème et surtout et
5 à tour c'est un échec
voilà un petit pion de plus
lp on est doué p honey et fusées 5
si on échange des cavaliers l'acf ça va
aller on va ramener le roi
sa 5 pouces et baies 5 pouces et b4 va
replacer le cavale pas je le fais
encaissé une pure là bas
je suis hyper mal joué mais bon c'est du
bullet rock très mal joué cette finale
on va repartir vers des quatre aller
comme ça va lui faire acheter atteinte
directe
allez on va mettre le pion aux 4
commencez pas à bien on va faire des
ruiz après venez on fait des ruiz après
c'est hyper longtemps on n'a pas fait de
ruiz alors puisque c'est si grave
eux c'est hyper grave
c'est hyper grave
mais bon on se bat mais on le re easy
fille après ça va on se bat bien enfin
on va claquer là
honnêtement pour l'instant ça me fait
pas peur je monte à fond avec le roi
j ai un peu rien mais bon
on se fait mater on va lui faire une
ruine il nous fait une anti ruiz quoi
ils empêchent la ruse le fourbe
bon on a réussi la stratégie dont petit
jeu mais pas forcément pour très
longtemps parce qu'il ya cette qui tombe
ça c'est pas forcément une bonne
nouvelle
leucate qui tombe ya tout qui tombent
entre ruiz mais bon c'est le secret de
la rue y soit fin quand tu es perdu là
ruiz t'offre des ressources c'est galère
à jouer on colmate
donc quand le match comme on peut
aya cavaliers 6 manar a jeté sur zurich
a eu six échecs
ok il faut qu'on reprenne notre objectif
de 2006 salon vallée pour l'atteindre il
est 20h30 temps de reprendre le sérieux
de près mouffe de partout de jouer des
finales
alors on la replace les fous ici
on peut replacer les pièces on sait 5,70
pas mal tour en d1
ah c'est pas la position la plus fun du
monde à jouer c'est pas l'adversaire le
plus fun du monde mais l'emmener à
s'enfoncer 6 quand même bon il sac mais
il n'était pas du tout obligé
enfin je crois ont valu un emmy mais son
cavale ça lui fera des vacances
on va les taper par là
ces packs grande facilité à gagner ces
finales ces derniers temps ce qui joue à
reconnaître assez pénible bâle est tombé
5 qui gagne et sur le champ
non mais finalement ça va
allez tout en prévenant valais on
remonte on remonte à 2006 allez vas-y
revient pas de rhuys cette fois ci
c'est pas mal à ce qui est en train de
faire il connaît ce qui fait toujours
chiant nous on aime quand l'adversaire
ne savent pas ce qu'ils font quand même
me colle un petit fond h5 lac est
désagréable de petits grains des
familles qui fait plaise va peut-être
faire un petit dam des deux membres lui
ont valu double et les pions mais j'ai
envie de te dire ok veut faire dame f5
on va lui coller le petit cavale des
cats dans la gueule on va lui prendre sa
la venue faire un petit tour g8 et f5
maintenant comme ça on va peut-être dû
dame cinq échecs le cas échéant
j'en ai dû faire dame 5 quand même ce
qui est peut-être pas super en fait ça
dépend
je sais pas peut-être si en fait je sais
pas mais quand même j'obtiens la petite
structure de pions qui fait plaise
je suis pas convaincu ma tête j'ai
fouillé 6 le retour voilà fou et je vais
m'arracher tant qu'à bon escient plus
revenu quoi et h4 dans le bon tempo
c'est parfait qui ont pas s'éloigner
dans ta gueule
ok tu te fais maths et comme ça c'est
bon allez on va y est on y est on
retourne au charbon à la plus solide
on va laisser venir
c'est pas une ruine ça c'est une mûre
tassin c'est complètement différent on
est solide au centre va on va bifurquer
avec le four avec le pion à f3 florent
b1 alors l'échangé
ça m'a l'air d'être semi correct coller
une tour on vend ça mange pas de pain
elle fait un petit fou g5 avant pour
provoquer du f 600 mètres le puits en c3
ce sera solide
allez on va passer la tour voilà collet
en e2 histoire de bien beaux bien
colmaté le truc
par jean va prendre on va faire dan d1
peut-être
je pense ça devrait aller ce qu'on fait
je crois qu'il ya plus d'échecs l' âge
etc choisi la mauvaise case à j'ai
choisi la mauvaise case à je perds tout
seul fallait aller à rouen mais c'était
fini sur ces petits manque d'inattention
je crois même l'image d'un manque
d'attention pardon il suffisamment enfin
j'ai vu juste après lui suffisent à
l'enjeu était mort alors là c'est
dommage lui faire re 5 1 contre 1
non
alors c'est mal joué ça pousse jeu
complètement à l'envers je joue
complètement à l'envers
j'ai joué complètement à l'envers cette
partie alors
là je joue très mal cette partie là joue
très mal
enfin c'est que j'ai pas du tout
d'attaquants fait
même c'est que je n'ai pas du tout
d'attac
le truc c'est que j'ai vraiment aimé ça
j'ai vraiment mal joué
y a rien à dire
ce match on était en train de le
remonter et je pense vraiment que je
peux le battre 1 mais voilà ça c'est pas
bon non plus bon ça j'aime pas du tout
avec les blancs walhalla c'est horrible
à ce que je suis en train de faire oh là
là mais c'est que des mauvais coups j'ai
juste juste en train de faire des traits
un enchaînement de très mauvais coup
voyez pas très très fort non plus un
douleur
c'est pas terrible ça non plus mais la
france et six depuis tout à l'heure non
mais quelle eau lalalalalala foot
français et 6,2 puis une plombe allez on
va vers ton proxis maintenant à le
ridicule ne tue pas heureusement sinon
je serais déjà mort à mainte et mainte
reprise trahi
heureusement que le ridicule ne tue pas
les mecs
sinon on serait mal
puisqu'on va faire grandement mais je
sais pas en fait suer
je connaissais jusqu'à la position
précédente en fait un bond
ma foi la position a l'air sympa mais
j'aurais pu mieux faire honnêtement
à avaler f5 là
non non j'ai mal joué j'ai mal joué j'ai
mal joué j'ai pas trouvé les bons plans
on espérait qu'ils prennent n'est pas
ici
voilà on est croyant foutu là
j'ai pas j'ai raté j'ai un peu raté à
certains moments
si j'ai la grande vente c'est ça ok bon
ça ça se joue
en mars un pastis et là c'est pas
forcément encore fini
fou c'est un calque ou de fouine
maintenant à la
je vais prendre un échec comme ça
m le cavalier maintenant est ce un pas
l'air de marcher à ce que je veux faire
ça fonctionne pas parce qu'il ya faire
un coup de dames
du coup je ferais fou ici si je peux pas
rater mettre le fond réussissent quand
même
ah mais j'ai le fou qui reste en prise à
je voulais prendre 2 j'aurais dû prendre
de la dame
aïe aïe aïe
aya les tours emprise de partout
mais peut-être plus trop de temps non
plus
si j'étais capable de trouver des
menaces mais j'arrive pas ok on souhaite
quand même dominé par ce mec je trouvais
pas si dangereux au début mais plus
dangereux que prévu
notre ami popov cavalier e 5
je commence à faire des grosses erreurs
je commence à faire des erreurs
notre exposition est super insipide 1
mais c'est bien ce qu'il fait ces
extraits le pion passé à là bas quant à
la bande des six
ma foi est ce qu'il aura pas laissé une
ce qui l'aurait pas laisser passer un
peu sa chance d'être mieux
ces deux contre-attaqués leroy jeu c'est
de faire tomber cinq tours b2 a
peut-être un peu sympa là ce qui vient
de faire pour moi je veux son roi doit
partir se balader et la tourbe et 5 c
cool avec lui par la menace g5 remettre
la dame en f3 on va jouer g5 matteau qui
ne l'a pas laissé ma tu es allé à il
fait pas de re match on était bien en
train enfin je pense que j'allais leur
montée franchement je pense que j'allais
finir devant
je pense que j'allais remonter
franchement je t'ai pas pour ne pas
quitter pas à 100% concentré à fond a
pas faire de blagues et où je pense que
j'allais remonter n'y a plus personne
qui joue de nouveau allez allez allez on
propose des parties
on se dépêche les tontons se dépêche
allez allez je propose un peu à tous les
jeunes
allez ouste at il joue pas mal il faut
lui faire le trois poisons
[Musique]
je pense pas mal d'ouverture non je fous
le 2
mark et moi on est tombé sur un frère on
aura joué exactement pareil évidemment
frère de sacrifices
sur une fois angers 2
ayad 1 prend
heureusement il a raté mais ça c'est
parra joue ici finalement donc on va
revenir mais du coup c'est un peu
embêtant aussi
du coup c'est un peu embêtant aussi on
s'est complètement marcher dessus
je sais pas vraiment s'il avait intérêt
à faire ça on va revenir là
je défends comme je peux 1
je sais font pas mal quand même j'aime
pas vraiment comme un lion
sans fermer sa propre retour maintenant
je file me faire mater quoi
non mais je bouge trop lent dans les
pièces pas possible
qu'est-ce que je suis lent bien défendu
quand même rare je vais pas faire j'ai
cinq pense pas grave c'était missclick
missclick en force
c'est tellement ridicule ce
développement
qu'on ait changé le fou à
le protéger
c'est super ridicule ce que je suis en
train de faire
pouvoir il y perd courageux il objet de
prendre ni amatan h2k il fait fort qui
les vitrines damage froide amjad et
hyper courage petit rock c'était très
courageux de sa part
j'apprécie tellement de temps à écouter
ils filaient utiliser tellement de temps
pour pour se prendre un math en deux
mais moi fallu reconnaître le bouge
voilà
bon alors qu'est ce que ça vaut cette
histoire ces quatre tout n'importe quoi
je suis mal
par contre on lui a fait une petite
faiblesse ici ça ça va être sympa par
contre on est très mal autant
par contre est très très mal autant
puis se mettre la pression à fond
il faut qu'on mette la pression à fond
voilà comme ça c'est bien même un petit
coup de dames f3 pour un pour bien faire
mal non ok on est presque à 2006 allez
on fait mal
fait mal ici
mais il fait mal ici on est complètement
fou tu vas faire ça mais c'est
complètement mort on va tout perdre
on a même plus de caleçon
j'aime pas trop vraiment comment lutter
avec la dame
on est complètement foutue sgg payet
tout vu en fait le pion ces cinq terrans
mal joué alors on va se faire mater
c'est dommage ont approché 2006 une
nouvelle fois on va les revend va les
retrouver
on va les retrouver on ne s'inquiète pas
allez
à pas de chance je vais mettre la main
ou 3 j'étais déstabilisé par sa défense
la b4 oh là là à la foire se ressaisir à
il fait fou prend en premier au lala
j'ai près move et tout ça tu
complètement oublié qu'ils pouvaient
prendre ici en premier enfin ça c'est
super fort en fait
du coup il va mater direct
obama et machin ok y'a pas tout à fait
math encore
je défends encore
de manière extraordinaire je suis encore
en vie
qui va donner ça
on a défendu un truc de malade aller sa
faiblesse est petit défense a fait paix
cette petite défense et anton et c'est
vrai qu'on a un petit problème de
connexion au cinéma c'est ouais c'est
désagréable et problèmes de connexion
puisque automatiquement on a perdu 15
secondes quoi et 15 secondes c'est vrai
que c'est pas à yaya y en a une valeur
un peu plus on peut pas lutter là si la
connexion siméon peut pas lutter
norman à l'afld on a perdu un temps fou
à ça tu peux pas lutter quand la
connexion te coûte autant de temps tu
peux pas lutter
dommage parce que je vais faire un petit
truc tactique que j'avais déjà fait un
autre joueur une fois en prenant ces
trois éléments et 6 on va récupérer
notre pièce et ça va pas être si grave
encore que si on avait du mal quand même
puisque son cavalier très bien placé
mais bon si on est quinze vingt secondes
de plus ça irait peut-être quoi
c'est jusque là t'as juste pas le temps
de jouer l'armée ok mais n'a perdu
facilement 15 secondes devant salah
pénible
pénible qu'est ce que je fais au nom
pourquoi j'ai pas envie 2
non
on va les récupérer sont fous peu la
bonne nouvelle
te prendre ici j'ai installé mon fou ici
qui aura les pour damages six ans
mettant g5 à protéger ça
et très bizarrement ce pas gagnant
très bizarrement c'est très mal payés
ça aurait pu être mieux payé cette
histoire
ça aurait pu être mieux payés j'ai pas
pris là nul est là
hamas
il a mal joué il a même fait jouer le
pas jouer le bon coup et est quand même
il s'en est pas sorti
féru 4-5 direct
on va venir chasser ce pion en deux
temps ok bon j'ai six on va venir là on
va venir prendre cinq mètres le front g7
ces quatre ce pas mal joué avec le foin
4 on va revenir comme ça
éventuellement on prendra et prendra ici
je vais faire grand roque du coup ça tu
pourras l'école matisse à au cas où vous
faire gaffe aux maths de bozene on va
chasser voile à l'école mattei 6
on va faire des quatre maintenant
les fous des cinq qui est chiant
l'entité serait convient que le roi
c'est chiant à jouer avec les noirs
c'est très chiant à jouer
je vais la perdre ou pas ils ces
automates est incroyable j'allais la
perdre celle là c'était très chiant à
jouer les fous étaient trop forts c'est
dur de jouer avec ces trois n'importe
quoi c'est une mauvaise position une
nouvelle fois
j'espérais
liquid un peu de matos a réussi à tout
liquidé on va pouvoir jouer que quatre
appareils à plomber 2 qui reste on ne
prend pas heureusement
à se mettre ici du coup
à
[Musique]
je vois rien pour le moment qui
finissent le boulot
ok
on l'a fait un peu craqué elle revient
vallée 2006
s'il a été super déplaisant depuis tout
à l'heure
ils ont essayé de
prendre l'espace à fond mais je suis en
retard c'est chiant c'est chiant c'est
chiant il vaut mieux donner la pièce est
jouée cinq ans avec le gros centre pays
qui est pas si mal placé
même la tour prend à s'arrêter
il s'est complètement de la merde si on
n'était pas loin d'eux
4 je l'essayé je vais pour age 2
alors là si je me fais pas maté truc si
j'ai quand même un pion h qui est assez
violent si je me fais pas maté
jenson que je me fais pas mater comme
cette vague impression là tout d'un coup
devenir tout colle mal avec mes deux
fous
je vous met un petit échec intermédiaire
ça va être surprenant qui en met un
autre ici non non non je mets du temps
attrapé ma pièce je suis complètement
con j'étais vraiment complètement con tu
n'arrives pas à choper ma pièce avec ma
souris quoi je suis tellement nul à
forza est aussi et tous les jeux vidéo
je suis vraiment je suis en escargot
j'ai failli me après je sais pas je fais
n'importe quoi
je n'aime pas trop jouer ça en fait
j'aime pas joué cette position elle
n'est pas mauvaise mais j'aime pas la
jouer enfin salah concrètement c'était
pas top mais en général j'aime pas trop
jouer ce truc là je n'arrive jamais à
développer mon cavalier mon pions des
quatre est toujours en prise face et
l'enfer du coup ma tour et pas développé
dans mais c'est infernal
c'est complètement infernal surtout
infernalement mal joué et c'est de
prendre une fois la page attentes et ça
m'a l'air d'être tellement 1
complètement foutu non mais c'était sûr
j'allais perdre un petit coup ce truc là
bas on a reperdu et 2006 mais on y est
arrivé
dommage
will change son fusil d'épaulé du coût à
[Musique]
mais je pense bien que cette finale est
pas jouable 1 pour les noirs
malheureusement
je crois que cette position est juste
mauvaise pour les noirs
je tente un autre truc du cou fragile
faut prendre des quatre fers tourbe et 8
c'est ça le regarde à enfermer son fou
peut-être nous rapporter des dividendes
plus tard
ces cinq c'est un peu pénible et j'ai
pas tour c'est 8
wen en fait c'est pas terrible en plus
j'ai plus de temps
bon
je suis retourné en fermer le fou
aïe aïe aïe allez on joue contre avec
plus fort le mec veut perdre monde
toulouse
mais bon on de toulouse surtout en tout
plein et john varley shannon the slave
comme un fou peut-être d'ouverture quand
même plus originales pour le bullet la
grotte par exemple pour donner une idée
mais bon
du coup je voulais dire face à son
manque d'originalité
nous nous faisons remarquer par notre
originalité quoi aller boom et en a
marre amusons nous faisons des choses
marrantes mon cher ami
tous ont un pion
c'est un pion toujours marrant tu pars
de ce principe
mais j'ai changé les dames écouter
on les ferme at d'anastasia sympa le mag
d'anastasia là bas bon alors on de
toulouse allez on va faire un peu de 4
et on va répondre à son originalité par
plus d'originalité comme tu veux jouer
sans dames on va facturer des positions
chanterelle une position je suis un
talent hors norme de l'échangé la slave
décide de jouer qu'un truc plus fun
les protéger notre pions
leur proposition assez assez saine
alors
j'aurais pu gagner ça plus simplement
c'est sûr
pas méga propres
ça commence à prendre forme comme dirait
femmes
ça commence à prendre forme
comme en 2006 pile bon de toulouse à 11
ans a quand même bon allez hop un petit
monde toulouse traille va nous jouer sa
faune
à l'essai
qui s'ouvre la colonne là bas on est
triste vraiment on couvre bien
je vais faire un 4 et kébé 3 ya pas de
matane ya pas de menace même à écouter
il porte bien son pseudo celui-là
lors de même très bien son pseudo
je peux laisser mon père ça
je te prends du fou pour éviter fou eu 6
pas top j'ai peut-être mettre la main en
f3
c'est un bordel sans nom
empêche de faire grand roque faire f 5
quand même on la joue a plus rien là
y'en a trop de partout pour moi ci prend
là je vais prendre cette affaire d'âme
des sept matches et ben voilà monde
toulouse paris veut pas rejouer
il veut pas reperdre monde toulouse
à 2007 alors qu est ce que ça vaut 2007
l'offre économique réussissent à jouer
c'est quoi un drapeau fidji à l'affiché
on s'assoit bouge pas trop un an le chat
bas on n'a pas réussi l'adoption à une
godbert malheureusement moi je voulais
adopter
je voulais adopter ou à toulouse à
trenton 110 minutes de stream ont ce
crime jusqu'à 10 21h30 et du coup on
finit contre ce joueur 27
on va voir mais bon je vois beaucoup
plus de choses qui hier a clairement
it's not the same 1 c'est pas la même
ouais mais je parle en anglais avant de
dire mes phrases un fait très attention
c'est complètement bilingue ou c5 et
dégagent quelques fous la merde
j'ai envie de [ __ ] encore plus de
merde à sa merde
je te prendre avec la tour tu as voulu
[ __ ] la merde et ben écoute tu vas te
débrouiller avec ça parce qu'il y en a
partout
on apprend ici
je crois que s'en est très bien sorti
c'en est très très bien sorti chapeau
chapeau chapeau
c'est un échec ça
ok bien joué et bien joué j'ai pas j'ai
pas trouvé exactement comment le
comment le maîtriser le 2010 les forains
le mec il m'a l'air ne pas être mauvais
hein
mais rien ne pas être mauvais le le
tonton fidjien d'apprendre de la
tournant
je suis dans la merde
dans la méga merde madame f4 là il y
aura tous âges 6 à la fin
je suis pas super loin
arrivé tout prend peut-être
oh non
non il a poussé le pion le voleur âgé eu
à c'était mérité à ses une benne partir
il joue bien il joue bien il joue bien
c'est cool de finir sur lui
c'est important en terme de foutage de
merde j'y vais à fond contre lien
mais il est puissant
chaque et 5 quand même
on va faire ça il faut h 6
traille est chaud le tonton fidjien de
la tour plus tôt on va les matraquer le
cas mal
je sais pas à quel point c'est malin
peut prendre une fois je peux prendre là
je peux prendre la non non non je me
suis trompé sur le pré nous venons au
nom j'avais complètement dominé je me
suis planté sur le pré moon à j'avais
tout fait à j'avais tout fait
à la frustration maximale
j'avais tout fait comme il fallait
de a à z
la frustration de niveau 10 quand même
là
c'est très mal joué ce que je suis en
train de faire
mais voilà parties précédentes apporter
une telle frustration c'est complètement
raté là ce que je fais mais la partie
précédente a apporté une trop grande
frustration
3la surtout que l'un des deux nouveaux
gagnants
j'avais trop peur des scènes
on est revenu à l'est la der des der
discrètement coin là n'importe quoi là
j'ai j'ai enchaîné le mauvais avec le
très mauvais
parmi ces horribles affreux à jeter
c'est à jeter la prendre c'est cette je
peux pas prendre à deux je peux rien
faire
c'était du cac a repoussé d un parti
se sera pas fait dominer dominé quoi
pas vraiment été dominés à proprement
dire
contre cet adversaire aura pas de match
pour lui je peux prendre comme ça
ok est beaucoup trop rapide il était
très rapide là quand il s'agit de bouger
à la fin vous y gagnent là dessus mais
on a une position garde de nouveau
dommage dommage dommage mais à écouter
j'espère que ça vous a plu vous êtes
bien amusé en regardant moi je me suis
fait plein c'était l'objectif du truc
donc donc c'est cool je passais un autre
s'il ya autre chose après sur une chaise
comme jeter un coup d'oeil je sais pas
en fait
mais en excluant que vous soyez bien
amusé
excepté bullet vous et plus et puis je
vous dis je vous dis à bientôt les mecs
ciao ciao